foreign
Daniel yes Sir Daniel oh where'd you
grow up where are you from originally
um born and raised in East Los Angeles
um on third and fourth by everybody
knows the restaurant King Taco
so yeah after 7 10 right there
you tell me about your family growing up
um my family growing up
um
my mother was from a neighborhood known
as Westside conton and my dad's side and
my family which Raised Me is from
maravia
um I only live with my mom for a shorter
period of time like maybe until I was
like four years old that I was taken
away by social services and
um placed with my grandfather because my
dad was in prison at the time
so where's your mom lose you my mom
loves me because of her addiction she
was um in and out of prison and
she was fighting a battle that I mean I
don't think she could comprehend how big
that battle was you know addiction
anybody that fights addiction knows how
hard that is you know
so yeah I got taken away
um Social Services had me and my
grandfather and grandmother my my mom's
mom they went to battle for me like in
court so they were I was in and out of
court for a couple of years I've been
trying to get custody of me until I was
finding a place with my grandfather and
raised in East Los Angeles
how would you describe your childhood in
general
um
my childhood in general was
not good I was um I used to see my mom
um use heroin well we call it slamming
dope so I used to wake up to that almost
every morning
and um
she's the in the meantime while her
boyfriend at the time he was one of the
like a real well-known dealer he would
leave to work and he would leave her to
sell dope throughout the day to make
money for her and she would be using a
lot of a lot of it so when he would get
home you know she didn't have a lot of
the money wasn't accounted for or a lot
of dope was missing so she would get
beat down like that and that happened on
The Daily like so I got to see that
happening that was a very um
that's a it's a massive thing for a
little kid to see you know and and I
can't I couldn't do nothing to help her
what could I do you know I'm just a
little boy yeah but um yeah he placed
his hands on me a couple of times and um
I don't know I don't I can't remember
how I was taken away but I'm sure
they've seen bruises on me or whatever
so yeah Social Service that I got
involved in and she ended up going to
prison
um that guy thinking he went to prison
for a little bit and I got placed with
my grandparents while my grandfather on
my dad's side
and you're living in a
a neighborhood where gangs are thick
well yeah so my my grandfather Me
growing up on my grandfather's side my
grandpa my grandfather was actually a
first generation from my neighbor
maravia so maravia how I was raised was
it wasn't a gang a gang thing like a
gang aspect like um he would talk to me
about how we were a righteous Barrio
like um we we protected our people and
um I was raised in that sense of there
was just the respect of our people you
know you gotta this is this is your this
is your community so you gotta take care
of it but then I got the whole
the whole knowledge of the of the real
gang banging when my dad came out of
prison and then he um he just put me up
on a lot of stuff where you know how to
conduct yourself as a man this is what
we're really fighting for and um you're
always going to be uh fighting with with
you know different other other
neighborhoods that are always trying to
prove themselves so you gotta you gotta
always be the aggressor like um
you you can't wait till somebody hits
you up you got to be the one and
especially because I'm short in stature
you know I gotta be the aggressor and
the dominant one to show to show force
that you know don't don't mess around
did you join the gang at what age
um I joined again on January 5th in 1992
on my birthday my guy jumped in I was 10
years old 10 years old yeah
I assume you've done some jail in prison
time
um I've done quite a few jail time
um fortunate not to hit the prison
system so very thankful I have life
sentences that you know I think God was
with me for the most part because I
overcame that
what is it about a young man that makes
that gang life so attractive
I mean is it attractive are you forced
into it or there's no choice for you how
do you feel all the time
um for me was more of a of a family
thing it was more my grandfather my
grandfather my dad my dad was in my
neighborhood
um and these were yeah they were they
were my role models but not only them my
my grandfather was older he was an older
gentleman he was um he was born in 1918.
my dad was born in 1940. so these were
already my dad had me when he was 42
years old already so all his homeboys
that would come over to the house they
were all older like what you would
consider veteranos already and the
respect that I seen in them and that
they showed me because of my dad and my
uncles
um it was something that I think I
craved like I I wanted that I seen I
wanted to be respected like that so I I
seek that out you know with different
guys that I met when I was when I got
busted or even out here like in school
like I wanted that I wanted to um I
guess wanting to make a name for
yourself you know wanted to show that
that alpha male like you know I'm the
leader I'm the one I want to be picked
first for basketball I want to be this
and that
but um yeah I think it's something that
I searched for was more of a family
thing with me
um there's different reasons why people
join gangs now like you know for to show
out or you know just looking for a dad
that they didn't have or whatever I mean
obviously I have my dad in my life he
was always in and out of prison but I
did have my grandfather so I that's no
excuse you know but I think I still
search for you know somebody probably to
look up to that was around my age
bracket so um yeah I got into my
neighborhood and at a very young age
um and I had no comprehension of what I
was really getting myself into with the
whole politics side because at that time
my neighborhood
um was going at it with a certain
organization that was you know running
the whole show and and that was a force
to be reckoned with you know and
especially at a little boy
um going at it with older men you know
that I had no idea
you know so um I really had to be on my
p's and q's you grew up fast you had you
had a run before you can crawl
and Maravilla is is one of them I mean
there's a lot of notorious gangs
especially in LA but Montevideo seems to
be like that one of the most notorious
of all right
what was the history of montevie do you
know so the history of Arabia um it's a
righteous what would you consider a
righteous Barrio or town
um before East Los Angeles was he was
even like named the Los Angeles this
side of would be the the bridges that
connect downtown Los Angeles
um was a town of maravia when the
borders were still open between Mexico
and the United States
so yeah a lot of our our older homeboys
would be considered pachucos
um they would actually go at it with
like um military personnel that were
partying or on leave and um that that's
where the whole story of those useful
riots come in to play and um just our
people were were
how do you say it where um
suppressed you know like look down upon
like we were less than or we weren't
good enough
um my grandfather at that time
um he actually you know he actually
tried to join the Navy he did join the
Navy and um he seen the same I don't
want to say racism but kind of it kind
of is you know looked down upon and you
know you couldn't move up and rank you
know you couldn't um they always had um
and it's not a racial thing but I I
think it's kind of like they look down
on our people you know that we weren't
good enough to be a certain rank or
whatever you know that's what that's how
he explained it to me you know so he
ended up leaving you know the Navy and
just coming back and um
living his life he got married and you
know everything that I learned from I
learned from him and
as a young man as a 10 year old boy
right you uh when did you first realize
you were into something much heavier
than just
joining a club and that um I think
within the first two years when
uh
older gentlemen are are um you know they
see who I'm hanging out with
um fights that we would get into when I
would go like to grab food with older
homeboys or whatever
and um yeah it wasn't no game you know
it was a it was a situation I was put in
where you can't run if you run your your
own homeboys are going to get you you
know so you really have to um
you have to show you know that you're
down for it you're down for the cause
you're you're down to ride with your
homeboys and then and not only that
you're down but it's something that you
believe in that you want to show you
know we're we're like everybody says the
gang members know that our neighborhood
is the best or our neighborhoods the
deepest or our neighborhood puts in more
work than your neighborhood and that's
something that I think a lot of
neighbors like my for myself at that age
I was very ignorant you know I thought
that I thought that we're the number
we're neighboring you know we're the
deepest we're the first neighborhood
like you know we got to put it down you
know we got to show that and that we
look down on other neighbors like you
ain't nothing you don't live in a
righteous neighborhood you ain't um you
don't live like like we live you know so
um and little did I know you know
they're living the same they're living
the same way you know I just I just was
stuck in that that that mindset because
of you know how I was raised
you know but yeah it was a very um it
was a very messed up time but what kind
of activities does the gang get into in
the community I mean are you are you
controlling some of the yeah where where
um I mean
as much as I want to say we're
protecting the community we're
destroying our community we're taxing
um local vendors where um
um also while we were trying to be taxed
by our organization you got to watch out
for homeboys that are playing both sides
you gotta um you know at that time Rocco
Kane was still very prevalent in the
neighborhood so you know you had to
learn a way to make money also so you
could get guns or you could get a car or
whatever because you want to show that
that um you know you look at an older
home but you pull up in a nice ass car
you want that too and you go hey how do
I do that how do I start off and and I
remember bringing an older homeboy into
my house I remember I was 14 years old
and I stuck them into my I snuck them
into my house and um he brought like
half a key into my pack and then he was
showing me how to rock it up like this
whole brick of cocaine and I'm right
there all fascinated you know at this
this gang member that's all blasted
tatted up and you know I have them in my
house I'm trying to have them be quiet
because I don't want to wake my grandpa
up you know and um he's showing me how
to how to cut dope up and make money and
get what he had he had three low riders
he had an SUV he had his own house
already and he's only what 24 years old
23 years old
and but I looked up to that like I
wanted that everything that respect that
he got now it was something not I mean
my grandfather taught me like a
righteous side but now it's more of a
dominant side and and on mischievous
side like you know when I I wanted that
I wanted that I wanted to pull up in my
ride with my with my strap and show
Force I wanted to get that respect of
hey you know homeboys coming down or
whatever I wanted that I think a lot of
young homeboys want that yeah it's
almost like a young male thing yeah
yeah it's so heavy in their veins yeah
they're violence and
domination and all that kind of thing is
is just part of who they are at that age
yeah really
do you find you've mellowed now how old
do you know I'm 40 years old
um I feel like yeah definitely mellow
down definitely
um but I think um and I don't want to
say it's a downfall but in a way it is a
downfall because I still demand respect
I still um
I still conduct myself a certain way
when I'm around certain people
um just because I know how they are or I
I think I judge people a lot which maybe
I shouldn't but that's how I feel I'm
still alive by judging because most of
the time I've been right you know if I
feel a person is is up to something like
trying to snake me out
um I want to have the upper hand you
know so yeah I think I'm you always got
to be ready you know that day that you
you decide to relax or or just chill
that's the day you're gonna get taken
out you know and I don't want I don't
want to be taken out a big thing and
growing up when I was younger was you
know my dad told me that you don't ever
want to get taken out by somebody trying
to earn their name like a nobody you
know make sure that that somebody is
um like is up there in the game you know
and um
you know that's I don't want to get
taken out by somebody trying to earn
their name I don't want to I don't want
to get caught slipping or lacking as
they say today
um so yeah I try to stay ready even when
I'm with my children you know we're
going to grocery store or I pick out a
pickle gas station to go to you got to
know the neighbor that you're going into
you know you got to know the politics
and the in that that neighborhood that's
going on you know that neighborhood
might have a green light or your car
might look like somebody in that
neighborhood that just shot at another
neighborhood so you got to be prepared
for anything you know I have my
neighborhood in front of me in the back
of me so they could see me coming it
just takes a glance into my car to see
the back of my head or the front of my
head so I gotta really be prepared you
know this isn't a guessing game this is
I I know that guy from aravia is right
here this is the kind of car he drives
this is where he works at so you gotta
You Gotta Be You Know ready at all times
the the concept that joining a gang is
you know lead to either
a life in prison or a life in a grave
does that
hit you as a young man or do you just
like ignore it and move on
um known for us well for myself um it
wasn't anything to ignore it was kind of
being prepared for prison they're
literally preparing you for prison
um everything that I got taught from my
dad which um it was um it was wisdom in
there your dad spent how many years in
prison uh he was in and out of prison he
did five years went back did like seven
years went back did you know four more
years my uncle the same thing my
cousin's the same thing
and and it seemed like my house was like
all the homies from Arabia and not not
just for my clique but like from
different clicks around my house
um so I got that we call it klecha or
class we got that that um that schooling
from them you know how to how to make a
shank how to um how to cook in there you
know
um you're getting all this etiquette
shown to you of how to conduct yourself
in person yeah in prison and we're out
here in the street we're little kids
like you know why why are you teaching
us that but
learning all that at a young age I think
it benefited me too because it's it's
showing how to conduct myself with them
with men out here in the street there's
guys that come out of prison and they
expect you to show respect they expect
you to say excuse me when you pass them
by they expect you not to step on their
shoes that's a big form of disrespect
walking in front of somebody and not
saying excuse me not looking a man in
his eyes when you shake their hand
that's a big formative disrespect and
now it's gotten so watered down where
you know guys use the word [ __ ] they
use the the you know the word even the
word fool like to say what's up fool
like that's just don't [ __ ] talk to
me like that who the [ __ ] you think
you're talking to you know
um
it's just a you know it's there's
different levels of respect that that
certain individuals demand and I think
learning from these older gentlemen at
that time I demanded the same thing as
them so you know to to run into a
homeboy that was around my age at that
time that wasn't getting that same
schooling it was kind of a shock to them
what do you mean like don't call you
fool like yeah I'm [ __ ] cracking in
your mouth like don't talk to me like
that
so you know you got to show it with that
you know you can't just talk about it
you can't just say oh I'm this type of
person you got to live like that you
have to live like that
do you feel like the uh The Gangs
especially in La have become
more watered down or weaker than they
were when you or your father right real
watered down throughout the decades
Generations it's real watered down our
our neighborhood is a generational
neighborhood like a lot of if you talk
to a lot of the the well around my age
or maybe in their 30s early 30s maybe
late 20s their their dads are from
native neighborhood their grandfathers
were from the neighborhood their
grandfathers were pachucos too
so um it's a it's just to pass down you
know I think in the 90s though it
started getting watered down when they
started implementing all these new laws
you know as I was going to ask do you
think it's law enforcement that's
created that or is it just society as a
whole has become the men and become more
spineless or something like that I think
not spineless but I think not knowing
the true foundation of what we what
we're supposed to stand for
and um getting a whole generation locked
up and incarcerated like with the three
strikes law and now you don't got
fathers that are able to give that that
to their or pass that down the guidance
so now these kids are are learning from
hip-hop they're learning from the rap
game they're learning all this stuff and
you know you got you got which in my
days the homeboys never use that you
know the n-word they never use that
you know and now you've got a whole
bunch of homies using that word and they
have no idea what that term means you
know that's not our culture that's not
we're not supposed to conduct ourselves
in that manner you know so it's kind of
like you know people that are that are
around my age we kind of we frown upon
that you know it's not the way you
should conduct yourself you should
respect your mom you should respect your
your elders you should um you know look
out for you know the women in your
community walking with the children they
should feel safer around you than they
do around the cops you know you have
children yes I do sons are daughters I
got I have 10 kids I have six six boys
and four girls oh wow so you're you're
boys do you do you see them following
dad's footsteps
[Music]
um
I've seen some of them try
um but then again I didn't raise them
like that I've been there for my baby my
kid I call them my babies but they're my
my children you know I try to everything
I I show them or teach them I don't ever
want to give them the short answer I
want to explain it to them them into
detail like but they see Dad with all
the uh they see me they see me and they
want just what I wanted
you know so I know the more that I try
and stop them the more it's going to
push them to Rebel
so I try to just have a relationship
with them and explain things and why you
shouldn't do that or the choices you
know
show them the the downfall that I had in
my life you know being homeless or
getting addicted to dope you know when
they're trying to explain to them so
they don't do it you know it's going to
be in front of you but this is a
decision this is the outcome that's
going to happen you know you're going to
get busted you're going to go to you're
going to do life or you're going to be
dead
and they know that listen I have a lot
of homeboys that have passed away from
overdose from getting shot by the cops
from suicide
um yeah so I try to you know I just try
to have a relationship with him
before anything before I say no don't do
that I think the first thing is as
parents we tell our kids is the first
word that they learn is no they're going
into the cabinet no don't do that no no
no
instead of saying this is why you
shouldn't do it
teach them to think right
if you had your life to live all over
again do you think you you would have
done anything differently definitely
definitely I think um I still I still
think the wisdom that I got I call it
wisdom for my dad and my my grandfather
and my uncles
um I think it was very important it's
very important to be Street Savvy to
know where you're at people might might
look at this and say it's it's an
ignorant thing or you shouldn't live
that or you should have finished school
or you should have did this and that and
I think my answer to that is schooling
starts at home
schooling starts with your moral system
school starts with your with your
etiquette with your parents showing you
how to make your bed with them showing
you how to make breakfast how to how to
take care of yourself because one day
I'm not going to be here and I'm gonna
hope that my kids
um have that moral system embedded in
them you know
that they're going to be able to conduct
themselves around other men so they're
respected and not disrespected you've
got everybody disrespecting everybody
and especially people that they don't
know I tell my kids about you know I
hear a lot like I I was hanging around
with my kids one time and their friends
were gossiping about other people and I
tell them you know
when you when you hear somebody gossip
about somebody else you're only getting
five of that five percent of who that
person really is you don't know who that
person is that person could end up being
your best friend that person could end
up giving you putting money in your
books when you're busted that person
could could save your life one day
I tell people that
don't don't disrespect me you know don't
doubt you know how far I've come I could
be the person to save your life one day
but I could also be the person to take
it
so I think you should come out with
everybody with respect you know
you've been in love before
yes I have
yeah I've been in love
um
I always said when I was younger it's
funny I always said I wanted to be
married at 25. I don't know why that was
an age a good age for me or that I
thought it was
today looking back at my age now that's
a young age you know but um
I think um Love is a beautiful thing you
know I think that a lot of people have
misconstrued love though yeah you know
they say they're in love with somebody
and they're just in like with them or
they're just content with their everyday
systematic way of living
that they become privy to I don't think
that they're in love and they go in and
get married because they want to put a
label on it or stamp it and most the
time that ends in divorce and that's sad
you know most people that haven't gotten
married
stay together for the longest period of
time that's beautiful
to wake up to wake up to somebody that
has your back
somebody that wants you wants to push
you to do better
somebody that's going to correct you
when you're wrong even if they love you
I think correction is love
you know or love I mean correcting the
person that you're with you know
what do you think the whole gang
attraction is
is I mean I I see you don't see you only
see like the lightning Latin American
communities or the
African-American communities kind of
getting involved usually there's not
many white gangs so
um what why what do you think that is
it is it the the poor the fact that
these communities are poorer
I think literally from
um I study a lot I read a lot
um I I think I'm a deep thinker
um I think it's a it's it's a system
that we're putting to
part of it to do with gentrification
a lot of it to do with um
certain restrictions that are put on our
so-called minority communities
um
and come to find out we're not a
minority we're not we're a majority of
people out here we're deep black and
brown
um
yeah so I think it's a it's a it's a
system a systematic thing like you know
that we're put into it also becomes a
mindset too right and it becomes a
mindset you know why is there liquor
stores in every corner
why do we have all this stuff why do why
does our rank go up you know why do we
get pushed out of our communities
you know it seems like we're getting
pushed out every other day we're getting
pushed out of something look at the
whole Dodger Stadium theme
you know
um those are three communities that got
pushed out you know to build the stadium
for what why why do these people get
displaced from their houses
you know the 710 freeway when my when my
grandpa you know was younger a lot of
his friends got taken out of their homes
to build that freeway yeah we do need a
pathway to travel but you know don't
just rip people out of their homes you
know this is where you live imagine
somebody going to your mom's house and
ripping her out of her house
you know and telling her you know
to get out of here
the violence that you get involved in
when you're in a gang it gets pretty
extreme sometimes definitely do you have
any examples of things you can share
yeah
um
you don't need to name names
yeah that's what I'm thinking about
I've had a lot of good friends die I've
had a lot of good friends die get set up
you know by the police
um I've had friends
um I'll give you one story without any
means I had a good friend of mine he
used to um he used to look out for me he
used to help me fix my I used to have
back in in the 90s GT GT um you know
dinos and the whole bicycle thing was
really cool and you know we everybody
wanted a bike if you had a GT Dyno or GT
freestyle that was a thing to have you
know so um this guy would help me fix my
bike together put my you know pegs on it
and all this and that he used to give me
a lot of schooling in the neighborhood
and um he got involved in like a lot of
politics stuff and um
he got thrown off the freeway
he got thrown off the freeway because
he'd want to pay a certain amount or he
didn't want to pay no amount
and um he was still alive and he crawled
to try to get off
and they went down there and threw him
into several more cars
and the people that did it paid for his
funeral
that's crazy like who does that but
that's how how treacherous this world is
that's how treacherous you find homies
to be a lot of people don't know a lot
of younger homies don't don't get that
outside until you get involved in some
real some real stuff it ain't just about
hopping the hopping out the car and
going to go hit up a dude in the
neighborhood
um a lot of politics get involved in it
you know I'm not gonna get deep into
that but you know a lot of it has to do
with money and a lot of people are
willing to do a lot of a lot of evil
[ __ ] over money you know even sell out
their own family members so you got to
be very very careful you know
you're around for the drive-by era right
yeah
yeah the drive-by era was um we we
actually got um you know we call them
juntas with their meetings and um that
was a big No-No you got a green light if
you did a drive-by if you don't get off
the car and it was a whole thing like we
never we never respected that anyways
you know you'll find very few of our
homeboys from my neighborhood and not
trying to beat boss one anyway but our
homeboys really never did that you know
we get off the car and look you in your
eyes
you know the more the more personal the
more personal you got with within with
an enemy or a so-called enemy the more
um stature you got so why use a gun when
you could use a knife anybody could use
a gun but to get up and personal and go
toe-to-toe with somebody that that's a
man
that's a man you know
what character trait
is most valuable
in in a gang
is it Integrity is it uh
um
and uh it's not a good trait but
definitely not integrity
I think being a vicious person
to be to be yeah
you know there's a there's a saying in
that movie A Bronx Tale right where he
says would you rather be respected or
loved are are feared feared or love
right and um uh I think to be feared is
definitely
um Gonna Get You Somewhere in a gang the
more the more willing the more
willingness you have to do something
really
ugly that's what's going to get you you
know be a dominant person in your
neighborhood get you feared people are
going to be willing to listen to you
listen to your instructions
um go do damage to another neighborhood
um yeah you got to be really
um
you got to be really how do you say it
um strategical
you know there's a there's a
a lot of homeboys cross out their walls
and I talk about this was in my younger
younger days
when we used to ride on walls and you
see neighborhoods hit up on walls and
they go like a minute later they're
crossed out
like why are you gonna wait for somebody
to cross you out
we used to wait for them to cross the
South across the street three cars down
wait to see let's wait for them and get
them
you know not saying murder or nothing
but you know give them the Beatdown of
their life
you know
um don't ever give the opposition a
chance always be always be on the the
offensive
you know
do you believe in karma oh definitely
definitely how does karma play out in
your life
it plays out every day
every day and I'm sure I still got a lot
of Karma and I know it's gonna fall back
on my my kids so now I really try to
tiptoe about decisions that I make
um the way I conduct myself
um I don't want that that to come back
to them or myself
so
I just try to live by
I try to live a respectful life now you
know I take care of my kids
um I'm a tattoo artist now
um
so I just try to lead by by example I
don't want to I don't wanna I don't
wanna be that guy no more I'm not trying
to be that alpha male no more you know
so I just I just want to be I want to be
normal I want to be accepted I want to
um I want to be loved
you know I don't want to be feared no
more I don't care about that
I wanna I want people to enjoy my
company I want people to benefit from
maybe things that I'm saying to them you
know
do you feel like life is unfair
in a way
when I get down to the whole system
systematic thing but in general no I
don't I I think it's pretty fair I think
that and it sucks
um to to say it like this but I think a
lot of people deserve what has happened
to them or what's going to happen to
them
um just because of their and I think
it's a curse on their bloodline
literally like if you're if one of your
forefathers did some evil [ __ ] that
Karma's gonna come back to you it's
going to come back to you clean your
life up
you know
what are you afraid of at this point in
your life
um
I'm afraid of dying with no
accomplishment
I'm afraid of
not leaving a legacy behind
I'm afraid of not being a good father
I'm afraid of um
losing people that I care about that I
love
um
I always I live by a mindset that what
are people going to remember you when
you pass away you know I don't want them
to remember me as a gang member I don't
want them to remember me as a tattoo
artist I don't want them to remember me
as anything but benefiting off of some
sort of wisdom I gave them one time
hey he helped me out or he told me not
to go do this
or he was there for me to talk to me he
gave me a hug one time
um he took me out to lunch and was there
for me at my time of need
I would like to be known for something
like that
[Music]
Daniel what would you say is the most
important lesson you've learned in your
life
the most important lesson
is
there's so many
um
it's a great answer there's so many bro
um
live life with no expectations we expect
so much from people because of how we
were raised but we have no idea what
they're going through
you know we shouldn't expect so much you
know we may want that but
you know I think when we ex we're all we
always let ourselves down especially
when we're in love with somebody else we
expect them to be a certain way we
expect them to be the most loyalist
person in the world and we that's our
downfall you know we get that down we
get let down and that affects our
our spirit
you know we end up conducting ourselves
a certain way acting foolish being
spiteful being resentful and we go make
stupid decisions because of the
expectations that we had of another
person
so just be happy be happy for what you
do got be happy that you woke up and you
have breath in your lungs be happy that
you get to wake up and learn from
somebody you're watching on YouTube
be happy that somebody took the time to
conversate with you
all right Daniel thank you so much for
sharing your story thank you bro
appreciate you thanks man